all righty folks so
i'm gonna review some of these super
bowl commercials i was actually at the
big game
all right and uh i was in the crowd next
to a bunch of cardboard cutouts so i
actually didn't see these commercials so
some of these time watching
for the first time you will get my live
reacts in just a second this video is
sponsored by our friends over at raycon
alrighty first commercial is amazon
alexa
it's just flawless isn't it i think so
yeah
i mean i literally couldn't imagine a
more beautiful vessel for alexa to be
inside alexa
how many tablespoons are in a cup there
are 16 tablespoons in a cup
babe food just got here why are you
cooking
who's that alexa turn on the sprinklers
honey i already ran the sprinklers
things will get way too wet around here
alexa dim the lights
but
[Music]
add bath oils to my shopping list alexa
no
don't do that read my audiobook i was in
his hands
i was being changed
that i was also kissing him honey other
people have to use the bathroom around
here too
okay so i'm just gonna make a one one
little point here i get the joke i do
it's okay reverse the sexes this would
be the most hated commercial of the
super bowl by a long shot
right reverse the sexes for one second
which by the way would be a typically
male thing to do
right male ha men tend to have sex on
the brain a lot it would be absolutely
despised by the entire chattering class
but if you do it this way then it's
considered witty and humorous
so that is that is the way that this
this works like think about it for
for five seconds and you know that that
is a that is an absolute fact
right if that commercial were just a
dude thinking about
you know any hot woman from the movies
that would be
considered sexist how could she
objectify herself like that but because
a woman objectifying a man is totally
fine
okay hey ratchet stuck
i'm you jake from state farm you
couldn't find a standard looked anything
like me
have you seen mine it's like looking in
a mirror right
now that one makes sense look guys i
don't even have a stand in of course you
do
hold on is that drake that's right drake
from state farm
like a good neighbor like a good
neighbor
stand-ins don't have lines oh okay
like a good neighbor state farm is there
yeah it didn't do it for me i mean i
will admit that any time paul rudd is on
screen i laugh
but that's pretty much the only thing
about that that i
understand i don't even understand what
they're what they're going for there
like hey look celebrities who don't look
like each other that's
funny not really next did you know that
norway
sells way more electric cars per capita
than the us
norway
well i won't stand for it
come on never mind
with gm's new ultim battery we're gonna
crush those
losers crush them let's go america
keenan norway's out evening us wait
what's this
oh it's my daughter's birthday she's
really a pirate i don't care
grab an eevee meet me in norway can i
say goodbye to my family nope all right
aquafina sorry to disturb you but
norway's beating us at evs
uh-huh meet me there in an hour can i
ride with you
no gm's ultim battery is made for all
types of vehicles so soon
everyone can drive an ep
whoa why didn't we all just go together
knowing wheel is probably flying private
hey norway listen up you fish loving oh
this place is adorable damn it
where are you guys we're in finland
where are you
i'm in norway norway you're in sweden
oh damn it
[Music]
okay so that's actually clever it's
clever i mean it's it's too much but
it's clever
if you're going to try and push
americans to buy
cars that they don't want to buy like
absolutely do not want to buy trying to
turn it into like an america versus
norway thing is actually
pretty good that's actually a pretty
good pitch they don't have the little
disclaimer with the asterisk underneath
it says with massive american taxpayer
subsidies did you steal my cheetos again
just tell him it wasn't you but i cut
you at the counter
it wasn't me
[Music]
saw you snacking on the sofa it wasn't
me
you even had them in the shower it
wasn't me
i even caught you on camera you're the
one who granted access to your snacks
don't talk surprise don't you see behind
your back you gotta keep times before
she emptied up but let's review the
situation orange fingers red flag
to keep you unstuck outside it better if
she asks where they are you say forget
to never admit to a word and please
don't upset her and if she keep on
snarking i guess
well did you
wasn't me oh
okay well that's the first time that's
ever worked
new cheetos crunch pop mix
okay so that is a joke with a with a
premise that lasts about seven seconds
before you get the joke
and it just keeps going and going like a
monty python sketch also
if you believe that uh mila cunus or
ashton kutcher have ever eaten a cheeto
or at least have since they were doing
that 70s show together
then you have another thing coming those
people i cannot imagine that they eat
cheetos
in their spare time that is that is not
a thing again it's it's these sorts of
weird in jokes
this is the problem with comedy one of
the problems with comedy is that the
people who write the comedy think
they're really funny when they're in a
room with other people who agree with
them
but like i like who's like you know what
we should do we should find
mila cunus and ashton kutcher we should
put them in a commercial for cheetos but
we should use a song that was relevant
like three years ago
and then it'll be super funny no
no it will not unfortunately that's a
that's a sad story
all right this local access message is
brought to you by ubereats
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to waynesboro party
on wayne
party on garth as a local access show we
want everyone to support
local restaurants but we'd never
manipulate you the way all these other
commercials do
oh god sure that's really sad
totally we're better than that yeah we'd
never shamelessly rely on a celebrity
cameo
right cardi b yeah eat local
or jump on the latest trend
[Music]
all right
okay that's that's funny that's a funny
ad i like that that was good that was
good
first thing cardi b's ever been in
that's watchable
[Music]
i feel bad for kicking your seat on
purpose i'm sorry for mansplaining
that's when a man i know what it is we
should have just told you it's a boy
i wish he didn't have to hear all that
sorry i called you karen
that's my name sorry your name is karen
i promise i will not eat any more of
your friends
really
[Music]
okay it might happen one more time
okay i like that commercial that's a
funny and cute commercial that is funny
okay
that's all i have to say about that
49-yard attempt
and that kid that is good first points
of the game
oh man am i glad that i elected to
receive
raycons oh yes raycon is disrupting the
electronics industry by designing
premium wireless audio for half the
price
without compromise they're doing things
differently than the other brands
out there from the way they design their
products to the way they price them
raycon prioritizes their customer
experience from start
to finish raycon offers their wireless
earbuds in a range of fun colors and
patterns
with a variety of fit options no
dangling wires or stems
the company was co-founded by ray j
celebrities like snoop dogg mike tyson
obsessed with raycon's plus redcon has a
45-day free return
policy raycon earbuds give you six hours
of play time seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass
more compact design for a comfortable
noise isolating fit
if you're trying to take a break from
screens but you don't want to feel
totally unplugged raycon wireless
earbuds those are the best way to bring
your favorite content with you wherever
you go like
your favorite podcasts or youtube videos
so click the link in the description
box or go to buy recon dot com slash
shapiro
yt to get 15 off your recon purchase
again that is by raycon.com shapiro yt
to get 15
off your purchase or just click the link
in the description box below
oh no
there's a chapel in kansas
standing on the exact center of the
lower 48.
it never closes all are more than
welcome
to come meet here in the middle
it's no secret the middle has been a
hard place to get to lately
between red and blue between
servant and citizen between our freedom
and our fear now fear has never been the
best
of who we are and as for freedom
it's not the property of just a
fortunate few
it belongs to us all
whoever you are wherever you're from
it's what connects us and we need that
connection
we need the middle
we just have to remember the very soil
we stand
on is common ground
so we can get there we can make it to
the mountaintop
through the desert and we will cross
this divide our light
has always found its way through the
darkness
and there's hope on the road
up ahead
a few things a few things so am i
supposed to take away from this
that bruce springsteen has become a
farmer because that was my number one
takeaway right there is that bruce
springsteen who is a dude from new
jersey so he is about as kansas as i am
right in fact this commercial officially
makes bruce springsteen
the second most awkward coastal elite to
put on a cowboy hat after yours truly
so my understanding is that him in the
words of iowa hawk cosplaying as tom
joad
is going to bring the country together
also when i think of
moderate middle-of-the-road people i
think of bruce springsteen a lifelong
democratic voter who performs at the dnc
that's what i think about now when i
think about things that bring the
country together i think about church
now i just would like to ask bruce
springsteen and the democratic party
you're going to leave those people to
their religious freedom if they decide
for example they don't want to perform a
same-sex wedding what what if the people
who go to that church
in kansas typically happen to be
pro-life what then what then
you are you want to common ground with
those folks
because literally the only things that i
heard there that that signify what the
content of the unity you are preaching
are what exactly that's supposed to be
dirt
right because we actually have the
common ground is actual dirt well whoop
they do we share a planet doesn't mean i
have a lot of common ground with
you know the houthis in yemen they don't
like me very much i would
is it supposed to be the american flag
because i was informed until five
seconds ago the american flag stood for
racism so it's okay now to put the
american flag up there
they should have had like just they pan
over and colin kaepernick is just
kneeling there
by the way tom brady did establish
himself in the super bowl as matt walsh
says is the second greatest
quarterback of all time behind colin
kaepernick so
yeah whenever people say unity and what
they actually mean is shut up
i get a little bit uh annoyed and this
rock star with the earring cosplaying
being a
down to earth cowboy who drives around a
beat up old jeep
is a is frankly somewhat insulting i'm
not going to pretend to you
that i am a dude who drives around a
battered old jeep through the country
thanks to my long history of farming in
los angeles
and south florida it is ridiculous i'm
sorry it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
brian stelter loved it though so it's
okay
don't think you're an investor we make
investments morning
noon and wait what time is it exactly
do we make short-term investments
long-term investments we diversify our
interests
realize our gains and losses and try to
keep the big picture in mind
you don't need to become an investor you
were born one
robin hood i mean unless you
shop gamestop like a lot then things go
wildly wrong
okay that's like a straightforward
commercial like a very straightforward
commercial
nothing really special there there's it
is amazing how in the super bowl it's
just like a bunch of stock footage
i'm not sure that they actually need to
cast these commercials there's like what
if we just had people dancing
like a field i don't what if we just
like make a commercial and we'll have
like a baby
that's being cute but also a person
crying if you just turned the sound off
you
you'd have no idea what these
commercials are about most of them which
is the mark of not a wonderful
commercial
mrs long yes we found a baby girl for
your adoption
but there are some things you need to
know
she's in siberia and she was born with a
rare condition
her legs will need to be amputated
i know this is difficult to hear her
life
it won't be easy
[Applause]
mrs long it might not be easy but
it'll be amazing
i can't wait to meet her
[Music]
we believe there is hope and strength in
all of us
toyota proud partner of team usa okay
that's a great ad
that is it that is a great shockingly
pro-life ad
what's amazing about pro-life messages
we've discussed in in prior videos
is that even when people are making
pro-life messages they don't even
understand they're making pro-life
messages because it just seems like a
good thing to do
and the answer is yes i mean the whole
basis of that is there's so many folks
in our society who would say that a
person with that rare condition should
have been aborted before birth
because after all that person is going
to lead a tough life that's a that's a
beautiful commercial and by the way the
power of adoption
i mean adoption is the greatest thing
that you can do for another human being
nothing but respect and and honor to
adoptive parents
that's amazing that's a great commercial
that's a great commercial and reminder
that every life is worth living very
very cool
miss davis tommy just brought me into
his office and whipped out his opinion
tommy i didn't just whip it out she was
into it plus i have a pretty big opinion
oh please it's not that big
she only gave me a second tommy not
everyone in this office wants your
opinion okay well how about you last
week at happy hour when you begged me
for my opinion i had a picture of
margaritas
i would have taken doug's opinion
you would no
we can't protect your opinion but we can
protect your car
cure our auto insurance okay i don't
know who came up with that
that is in fact a terrible commercial um
it's a terrible commercial because it
doesn't work on any level
it has nothing to do with auto insurance
number one number two
they're talking about opinions and you
think that there's a point to it but
it's actually just a really long
joke which like um
okay it's not even a good joke it's just
it's just a bunch of people talking
about
kind of but their opinions i guess so
yeah no that commercial doesn't work on
any level now i did see like some
amazing outrage over this commercial how
dare you this is so sexist people
the guy talking about how he whipped out
in front of this girl but he called it
his opinion
it's so terrible you can't use innuendo
like that and then the same people like
alexa commercial amazing
amazing alexa commercial hey how about
this everybody lighting up but also bad
commercial
truly bad commercial the producers have
asked me to pick my favorite and my
least
favorite least favorite it's always easy
because i hate things uh as far as
favorite we'll have to think about that
one so let's jump into that least
favorite commercial
clearly the jeep commercial on a
political level is just pap it's just
pap and it's annoying and it's and it's
silly
and bruce springsteen the cowboy
incurring encouraging us all to unify
from his perch at the dnc is a little
much
for me but as far as like the pure worst
commercial that cure auto commercial is
bad that is that is a bad commercial
again i don't know what the what was the
creative process that went into that
that was that was basically the hr
person was in a room with somebody else
from the company and they're like we do
auto insurance around here what should
we talk about like
what if it was a joke and the hr
person's like you cannot make a joke on
national tv you
absolutely cannot someone's like well
what if we call it an opinion done
let's make this happen let's spend a
million bucks on it yeah
not all jokes work gang not all jokes
work best commercial
clearly the toyota commercial just in
terms of the morality of it and the
decency of it what a great commercial
what a great commercial
so closing thought here after several
nfl seasons
that were just rife with woke politics
and anti-capitalistic nonsense it's
wonderful to see people spend millions
of dollars on commercials that other
people then critique as forms of
entertainment before buying their
products capitalism always wins gang